هنا الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصف وهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
روسيا توقف تنفيذا لهده من طرف واحد كيف
ترفضها وتصفها بالنفاق
الجمهوريون يسعون لتجنب المزيد من الاحراج
والانتخاب رئيس جديد لمجلس النواب
الديمقراطيون ما اسعدهم
غاراتنا من اسلام اباد على معاقل طالبان
باكستان داخل اراضي افغانستان تشعل الحدود
مجددا
توقعات 2022 تبدا في الحدوث مجزره اقالات
في امازون سيرا على خطى المنافسين عام
جديد بلا جديد
[موسيقى]
مؤقتا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه نبداها من
تطورات حرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه القصف
الروسيه على دنيتك توقف خبر صار طبعا
للجميع الحروب تؤلم الشعوب وان اختارها
القاده ربما يكون الامر مرتبط بهدله اعلنت
روسي عنها لمده يوم ونصف اعتبارا من منتصف
نهار السادس من يناير وحتى بدايه يوم
الثامن من يناير اوكرانيا في المقابل يبدو
ان هذا دخلت في عناد مع روسيا وصفت هذه
الهدنه بالنفاق وقالت ان اي هدنه محتمله
يجب ان تتضمن انسحاب الروسيه من اراضيها
اذا نحن امام تهدئه او تصعيد لا ثالث لهما
وامام التهدئه يظهر الاطراف تريد التوسط
من اجل الحل وهنا امسك اردوغان بهاتفه
واجرى مكالمتين الاولى مع بوتين الذي ابدى
افتتاحا لكن اشترته هو الاخر كما فعل
اوكرانيا اشترط قبولك يا ابن الحقائق
الاقليميه الجديده في مدعى اردوغان الى
وقفه اطلاق النار بشكل احادي الجائر
ولو قلي بوقف قصف دمياط المكالمات الثانيه
كانت مع الطرف الثاني زلينسكي حيث ابلغه
سعيه للتواصل لسلام دائما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
ومصابه اجريت مكالمه هاتفيه مع بوتين هذا
الصباح وناقشنا الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
بالتفصيل وتحدثنا ايضا عن ما يمكننا
القيام به في منطقتنا وقمنا بتقييم
العلاقات التركيه الروسيه ساجر مكالمه
هاتفيه مع الرئيس جريسكي بعد فتره وجيزه
وسناناقشون نتائج المباحثات التي اجريناها
مع الرئيس بوتين وكيف يمكننا تسهيل عمليه
السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا وتعزيز
اتفاقيات ممر الحبوب وقضايا الامونيا
والاسمده الروسيه
ردا على سؤال عن اقتراح موسكو بشان الهدنه
قال رئيس الامريكي جو فايدن ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يحاول تنفس الصعداء
بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 36 ساعه
لكن التطورات الميدانيه تبدو عكس كل
محاولات التهدئه التي ذكرناها استعصاء
دخول الروسي لمدينه باخموت دفع موسكو الى
تغيير الخطاب بابوابه المدينه ظلت مصابه
في وجه الدبابات الروسيه رغم الكثير من
المحاولات على امتداد سته اشهر المسؤول
الروس انفسهم كانوا اقروا بصعوبه المهمه
في باخمت من بينهم
القائد قائد مجموعه التي تقاتل هناك كما
ذكرنا امس فما هي الخطباء لموسكو بعد هذا
الانسحاب من باخر
صحيفه وسط الجورنال تحدثت عن تخلي روسيا
مرحله عن فكره الاستيلاء على باخمه وقالت
الصحيفه ان روسيا حولت مواقع المدافع
والدبابات من بخمه الى سوليدار من اجل
محاوله اختراق الجبهه من هناك ويكتسي محور
بخمط سوليدار اهميه خاصه بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه بعدما بات البوابه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه الوحيده للتقدم في عمق منطقه
مقاطعه دونيتك وتشكل ضخم وتواصل دار جزء
من الجبهه نفسها وتفصل بينهما مسافه 14
كلم فقط
وستحاول القوه الروسيه توسيعه فوق العسكري
الذي فرضته على بخمه ليشمل رسول الله
اسهل نسبيا في ظل تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
في باخم والتحصين الجيد هناك
في اوكرانيا سقطت مدن في قبضه روسيا ووجدت
اخرى من تلك القبضه محمود المدينه العصيه
على الجنود الروس حتى الان
عاقب قتال عنيف شهيده تلك المنطقه الايام
الماضيه
المكان هذا يكتسبوا اهميه كبيره بالنسبه
للروز اقلها معنويا
مع بسط سيطره على مناطق واسعه اما
اوكرانيا فتسعى بكل قوتها للحفاظ على
المدينه
الجيش فيها فشل القوه الروسيه مشينا الى
ان المقاومه القويه اجبرت روسيا على تحويل
اتجاه ناحيه مناطق اخرى محيطه احتضنت
المدينه قبل الحرب نحو 70,000 شخص بعد
مرور 10 اشهر على الحرب المستعره لم يبقى
فيها سوى ثم سكان اذن الجيش الروسي
ومجموعه
من واسع النطاق تمثل المدينه الاوكرانيا
حسما دفاعيا في منطقه الدونتس ولروسيا
تشكل بوابه استراتيجيه لسيطره على كامل
دومباز
احيانا يستغرق تطير المنزل اسابيع كامله
اليس كذلك
وروسيا تبقى بخموت محطه مهمه تدخل معها
الحرب نفقا جديده
معلق بين فوهات هذه المدافع
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
من جهتها هكذا رئيس المخابرات الاوكرانيه
تستعد لشنها جمال
رضيان
في سنيوز الامريكيه ان الجيش الاوكراني
سيشنها هجماته في جميع المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا من شبه جزيره القرمباس واضاف
انه يتوقع ان تكون المعارك الاشدره وفن في
مارس حيث ستكون الضربات اعمقه في الاراضي
الروسيه مشددا على اناشيد
ويبدو الحديث الاوكراني متفائلا للغايه
وهنا ظهر الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
النيته ينسس تلتمبرج ليعيدهم للواقع ويحذر
من خطوره التقليل من شان قدرات روسيا واكد
في كلمه ضروره حشد المزيد من الجنود
والمعدات والاسلحه للدفاع المشترك
وتابع من موسكو مع مراسلنا عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا هل هناك
بدايه اي رد روسي على ما اعتبرته اوكرانيا
الهدنه التي اعلنتها روسيا بانها نفاق
مساء الخير يا صهيب حط هذه اللحظه طبعا
موسكو عادته وتحدثت بان الهدنه قائمه
وستقف الاعمال العسكريه ولن يتم توجيه اي
ضربات اعتبارا من الساعه الثانيه عشر من
ظهيره يوم غد ولغايه نهايه السابع من
الشهر الجاري حيث يحتفل شعوب هذه المنطقه
بعيد الميلاد الحسبه التقاليد الشرقيه
لذلك طبعا موسكو مقبله ومستمره في الهدنه
التي وضعتها وتحدثت الدفاع منذ قليل عن
هذا الموضوع
حقيقه التطورات العسكريه عبد الجواد
فيما يتعلق خاصه باخموت وبعد الانتكاسه
والضربه الموجعه التي تلقاها الجيش الروسي
في مكيفكا والان هذه الهدنه همم ما هي
المعطيات حول سير المعركه وما تستعد له
موسكو في المرحله المقبله
صهيب طبعا ما حدث في اذانيتك عشيه راس
السنه كان ضربه موجعه بالنسبه للروس لذلك
طبعا القراءه العسكريه في البلاد تتحدث عن
المشكله الان تصعد كثيرا من عملتها
العسكريه ومن ضرباتها والارقام التي تتحدث
عنها وزاره الدفاع موسكو يوميا اصبحت
تتزايد بشكل كبير بما يخص طبعا قضيه احمد
حتى هذه اللحظه مشكله لم تتحدث عن
انسحابات من هناك قد تكون هناك اعاده
تشكيله
وغيرها من
المتطوعين بعقود في الجيش الروسي وهم
يعتبرون طبعا الاشرس بين الظارهم لذلك
طبعا معركه بخمط هي مستمره الجانب الروسيه
تحدث عن عدم وجود اي خطط لديه للتراجع او
الخروج من تلك المنطقه خاصه ان الحشد
العسكري كما ترى موسكو حتى تحضير اللحظه
لم يكتمل في تلك المنطقه وستقوم بدفع
المزيد من الجنود المختصين في مثل هذه
المعارك القتاليه التي قد تتحول لحرب
شوارع على شاكله ماريو بيل كما شهد الجميع
منذ نحو نصف عام من الان وتلك المعركه
ستكون من العيار الثقيل كما ترى موسكو
وكما ترى القراءه العسكريه في البلاد ماذا
عن التعاون مع بلاروسيا عبد الجواد هناك
حديث عن مناورات مشتركه بين روسيا
وبلاروسيا وهل حقا سيكون لها دور في
المعركه
صحاب يعني التعاون العسكري بين موسكو هو
مستمر منذ فتره من الزمن لكنه مكثف في
الاونه الاخيره طبعا للاحداثيات وطبعا لما
يحدث والازمه الاوكرانيه المجاوره للاراضي
البيلاروسيه طبعا الاتحاد الروسي
البيلاروسي العسكري هو يؤجل كثيرين حسب
قراءه موسكو خاصه ان موسكو تقوم بدفع
العديد من معداتها الثقيله الى تلك
المنطقه طبعا هناك طائرات مقاتلات مروحيات
دبابات قبل الجلد وغيرها من تلك الامور
يعني متوزعه ومنتشره في الكثير من
القطاعات العسكريه على الشريط الحدودي هو
غيرها من تلك المناطق لكن هذا التعاون حتى
هذه اللحظه لا موسكو ولا ميسي تتحدث عن
انه سيشارك في الدخول عسكريا ان كان بريا
او من الجو نحو الاراضي الاخرانيه صهيبه
عبد الجواد الرشد شكرا جزيلا لك مباشره
[موسيقى]
طلب مسؤول قضائي ايراني كبير من المدرعه
اغتصاب جنسيه على السجينات
اون لاين اتبع الى السلطه القضائيه وذكر
الموقع وانا مساعد الشؤون الدوليه في
السلطه القضائيه وسكرتير لجنه حقوق
الانسان كاظم غريب ابادي طلب من النائب
العام اجراء تحقيق المفصل في مزاعم
الاعتداءات الجنسيه والاغتصاب بحق بعض
السجينات وكانت مصلحه السجون الايرانيه قد
نفذ في وقت سابقا وقوع اي اعتداءات ضد
النساء في السجون وهددت بتقديم شكوى ضد كل
من ينشر مثل هذه المعلومات
وعلى الرغم من تعدد الانتفاضات في ايران
على مر السنوات الا ان انتفاضتهم هذه
المره تعد الاكثر خطوره على المحتاجين
وعلى الطلاب الجامعيين تحديدا
الجامعات الايرانيه القلب النابض
للانتفاضات على مر السنوات
لكنها انتفاضتهم هذه المره اكثر خطوره من
اي عام مضى لوضع نقطه نهايه للحكم القمعي
الايراني
[موسيقى]
النظام يزيد الضغط على الطلاب الى الحد
الاقصى بحيث لا يمكنك المشي او ارتداء
الملابس او التحدث او حتى الضحقوا بطريقه
لا تتناسبوا مع معايرهم
تقول ان نحو 700 طالب اعتقل خلال
الاحتجاجات واكثر من نصفهم لا يزالون خلف
القضبان بين احكام بالسجن واخرى بالاعدام
الطلاب يتعرضون للقتل والاعتقال والمنع من
الجامعه ويحكمون بسنوات طويله في السجن
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
خطروا كورونا يعود سلاله فرعيه من اومكرون
تقلق بريطانيا وتنتشر في امريكا
[موسيقى]
من التصويت الانتخابي رئيس جديد لمجلس
النواب الامريكي والثامن على مشاري في
الانتهاء لكن المحصله صفر لم يتفق
الجمهوريون ولا زالوا منقسمين حول المرشح
الانسب ولم يتمكن المرشح الاقوى النائب
على ولايه كاليفورنيا من نيللي دعم
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب الذي يسيطر عليه
الجمهوريين في الانتخابات النصفيه
هاوس
[تصفيق]
الامريكي السابق في وسط السيطره على الحزب
الجمهوري قد تذهب ادراج الرياح فترامب
الذي سعى الى تشكيل الحزب الجمهوري وفق
تصوره اختار اسماء بعينها لدعمها من بينها
قبل ما كافي ورغم دعم ترامب الا ان ماتر
في لا يزال يواجه اقليه معارضه لم تلتفت
لدعوات الرئيس الامريكي السابق صحيفه نيوز
ويك وصفت الامراض بان ترامب فقد السيطره
على الوحش الذي صنعه وتطرحه هذه الواقعه
تساؤلات الحزب ومستقبله كما انها تذكير
جديد بتراجع نفود ترامب داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
وهذا التخبط مشاهدينا في مواقف النواب
الجمهوريين قد يؤثر سلبا على الحزبه في
التحديات الانتخابيه المقبله بحسب مجله
بهذا الشرخ داخل الحزب من شانه
في الانتخابات المقبله كما ان اصطدام
المحتمل يلوح في الافق بين
اثارها كبيرا وقد يؤدي هذا الانقسام لفرغ
على مستوى مراكز القياده قادره على توحيد
المواقف والاراء
الى واشنطن نتابع مع مراسلنا من هناك حسين
الطود حسين انت في الكونغرس على ما يبدو
اذا
الجوله الثامنه للتصويت على رئيس جديد
لمجلس النواب الامريكي في طريقه اهل الفشل
مره ثامنه
بالفعل صهيب مره ثانيه وربما تاسع و10
طالما الاعضاء ال 20 ما زالوا على موقفهم
الرافدين مكارثي من ان يكون هو الرئيس
المقبل لمجلس النواب رغم الحديث البارحه
واليوم عن همم محادثات وصفت بالايجابيه
حتى من قبل هؤلاء
النواب ال 20 همم لكنهم اعلنوها صراحه
بانه مستعدون لتوسل الى حاله لكن ليس في
صالح مقارته هم مستعدون للتصويت على شخصيه
اخرى على مرشح اخر هو يرفع
ايصال مكارثي
بين الجمهوريه يعني هم همم من المؤيدين
للدولار ترامب ودونالد ترامب همم دعاهم
الى انهاء ما وصفه بهذه اللعبه الخطيره ما
المعلومات المتوفره حول الاتصالات التي
يقوم بها دونالد ترامب الرئيس السابق
ومحاوله تاثيره على الجمهوريين في النواب
هذا كان لافت انا صهيب لانه كما تفضلت
هؤلاء من مؤيدين دونالد ترامب ولم يستمعوا
حتى لدونالد ترامب الذي خاطبهم وقال لهم
ان يصوتوا على على مكارتي هذا امر كان
مستغربا ولكن يعني نستطيع نصف هؤلاء بانهم
ملكيون اكثر من الملك هم يقولون ان مكار
في لم يدافع اصلا عندما ترامب بما يكفي
خلال تحقيقات المتعلقه
باحداث السادس من يناير ايضا يصفونه بانه
معتدل اكثر من اللازم لديهم الكثير من
المؤاخدات على مقام حسب تعبيرهم طبعا
دونالد ترامب من خلال رفض هؤلاء همم
للتجاوب معه بشكل ايجابي والتصويت على
مكان يظهر ان همم الرئيس السابق فقد نوعا
من من حضرته والنفوده على الطيار المتشدد
داخل الجمهور الذي يؤيده بشكل مطلق
نعم في ظل هذا الجمهور الحسين نعم وهذا
الاخفاق المتكرر لسبع مرات على الاقل حتى
الان وربما الثامن في هل هناك اي اسماء
اخرى
يمكن يمكن ان تحظى
بتاييد غالبيه الجمهوريين ام لا
الاسم الاكثر تداولا هو اسم ستيف سكاليس
ولكن حتى ستمسكاليس لديها مشكله مع هؤلاء
حتى هم يقولون انه همم نفس المدرسه مع كب
المكارتي وحتى بالنسبه للمعتدين من الحسبه
الجمهوري العديد منهم يقولون ما الفرق ده
رشحنا سبسكلس الان سيواجه نفس المشكله مع
هؤلاء المتشددين لا يوجد حتى الان اسم همم
بمستوى همم همم مكارثيو او بمستوى اسكاليس
لكي يتم التوافق عليه رغم ان الاعضاء ال
يروجون للفكره همم وجود مرشح اخر ولكن ليس
همم مكار في طبعا وليس باسكاليس مرشح
توافقي بينهم بين الجمهوريين ولكن حتى
الان لا يوجد اسم حقيقي بقوه هؤلاء همم
ليتولى المنصب حتى
يصوت عليه حتى الان 200 همم نائب همم لديه
الاغلبيه المطلقه هؤلاء جميعهم حتى الان
يقفون خلفه ولكن العشرون نائبا لديهم من
القدره رغم انهما قليه جدا لكن لديهم
القدره على تعطيل ايصال مقارنه الى
الرئاسه
ومكارت به دوره ايضا همم يعني يظهر عنادا
ويقول انه سيستمر بهذه همم
جولات التصوير حتى النهايه حتى يفوز هذا
مكان ما ما طيب له قبل قليل قال انه عندما
سئل متى ستدرك انك
ان النتيجه هي ذاتها قال عندما افوز هو لن
يتراجع حسب ما يصرح حتى الان طيب همم الان
كما جاء في العاجل قبل قليل اذن مجلس
النواب يتجه الى جوله تصويت تاسعه يعني
الان مؤكد انه الجوله الثامنه قد فشلت
الجوله التاسعه ااه حسين ماذا سيكون فيها
هل هناك جديد فيها ام سيستمر التصويت
والفشل مره اخرى يعني الى متى
من المرجح ان يستمر التصويت والفشل مره
اخرى ولكن الان دائما يكون هناك همم
مفاوضات ومحدثات بين انصار مكه
قدم الكثير من التنازلات من المرشح ان
يقدم ايضا تنازلات ولكن لا يبدو حتى الان
انه سيتم همم تحقيق اختراق اليوم ربما في
الايام المقبله بالنسبه للتصويت كم عدد
الجولات هم لا يوجد عدد معين سيستمر
بالتصويت حتى يتم انتخاب احد همم النواب
رئيسنا المجلس اذا كان مكارثي او مرشح اخر
يتم التوافق عليه لا يوجد عدد نذكر انه هو
عام 1855 كان كان استمر التصويت شهرين بعد
شهرين استطاعه وان ينتخبوا رئيسا للمجلس
طبعا لذلك تداعيات حقيقيه همم حقيقه هنا
في الولايات المتحده اولا المجلس لان لن
يستطيع ان يمر اي مشروع من عمل اللجان
المتوقف همم النواب لن يستطيع اداء القسم
هناك الكثيره هناك شلل على مستوى ال ال
مجلس النواب شلل تشريعي الان تعيشه
الولايات المتحده وله تداعيات يحذر منها
الكثيرون منها موضوع سقف الدائن ومنها
امور كثيره متوقفه شكرا جزيلا لك حسين طول
مباشره من الكونغرس
[موسيقى]
معكم الان هذه جلسه خاصه لمجلس الامن
الدولي لمناقشه اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي الجديد اثمار بن غفير لباحاتي
المسجد الاقصى الان مندوب روسيا
يتحدث في هذه الجلسه الجلسه
القوميه في الثالث مليونير كانون الثاني
الحرم الشريف وجبل الهيكل وما اثره من انه
اثار الحفيظه وبطبع فهذه حادثه لا يمكن
نرى ابدا ان نراها بمعزل عن الاحداث التي
وقعت في عام 2000 عندما زار شارون محاطا
بالالاف في رجال الشرطه للام المدينه
الامر الذي كان مؤشرا لدلاع الانتفاضه
الثانيه والتي ادت الى همم
والتي اودت بارواح الالاف من الجانبيه
[موسيقى]
اذهب الى منطقه اخرى الاوضاع على الحدود
الباكستانيه الافغانيه تشتعل من جديد في
معبر طرحم الحدودي ووفقا لاعلام الافغاني
وقع اشتباك بين قوات الطالبان وحرس الحدود
الباكستانيه بدات قوات طالبان اطلاق النار
على الجانب الباكستاني ما ادى لاصابه جندي
باكستاني بالمقابل رد حرس الحدود
الباكستاني باطلاق النار الامر الذي ادى
الى مقتل مواطن افراني قبل ذلك وتحديدا في
ولايه نان جرهار شرقيه افغانستان ذكرت صحف
افغانيه ان القوات الجويه الباكستانيه شنت
غارات جويه على معاقل حركه طالبا باكستان
داخل الاراضي الافغانيه على الحدود مع
باكستان وذلك بعد ثلاثه ايام من اعلام
مجلس الامن القومي الباكستانيه العسكريه
على معاقل الحركه داخل افغانستان طالبا
باكستان هو بحسب وسائل الاعلام باكستانيه
ردت على هذه الهجمات حيث اكد المتحدث باسم
الحركه استهداف كمين للشرطه مع اسفر عن
مقتل ثمانيه من رجال الامن شهر ديسمبر
الماضي همم هذا الشهر كان الاكثر دمويه
اذا في هجمات طالبان باكستان على الحكومه
ويبدو ان هذا العام ستشتد المواجهه اكثر
وسط من طالبان الافغانيه
هنا ازمه جديده قديمه تطل على الحدود بين
افغانستان وباكستان
والعنصر المشترك فيها طالبان حيث تصاعد
التوتر الحدودي منذ استولى الطالبان على
السلطه اذا اتهمت اسلام اباد مجموعات
مسلحه بشن هجمات متكرره من الاراضي
الافغانيه
وتنفي حركه طالبان ايواء مقاتلين
باكستانيين اما التوام الايديولوجي
لطالبان في باكستان الجماعه التي تضم تحت
لوائها مسلحين مرتبطين بحركه طالبان التي
تحكم افغانستان فقد انهت وقفه اطلاق نار
استمر لاشهر مع الحكومه الباكستانيه الشهر
الماضي
ونفذت موته هجمات في انحاء البلاد انتهاء
وقف اطلاق النار في باكستان لا يهدد
بتصعيد العنف في هذا البلد فحسب بل يهدد
ايضا
بزياده التوتر عبر الحدود بين البلدين
افغانستان وباكستان
باكستان منذ ايام اعلنت عزمها شنغارات
عسكريه على معاقل الحركه مشيره الى ان ذلك
يقع ضمن نطاق القانون الدولي كما عينت
اسلام اباد قبل فتره مسؤولا عسكريا جديدا
على درايه تامه بحركه طالبان باكستان
وجغرافيتها في حين ان الحركه ومنذ مجيء
شهباز شريف كثفت منها هجماتها ضد الحكومه
اما واشنطن التي سبق وصنفت حركه طالبان
باكستان على انها منظمه ارهابيه لا تنفك
تذكر مرارا وتكرارا خلال الفتره الماضيه
انه يمكن استهداف طالبان باكستان وقادتها
قلق يتفجر من تفاقم الاوضاع عقب الانهيار
الاخير لوقف اطلاق النار المهتز بالفعل
بين طالبان باكستان واسلام اباد
ونتابع من اسلام اباد مع رحمه مسعود
الصحفي الباكستاني سيد محسود اهلا بك معنا
في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه اسالك
عن الوضع الان في على الحدود الباكستانيه
الافغانيه هل هذا التوتر الذي اشتعل بين
طالبان باكستان والحكومه ام ليس بعد
ماتش شكرا الافغانيه
اه وبراسه الطالبان تؤكد على احترامها
الاتفاق الدوحه الذي يمنعها منه مهاجمه اي
بلد مجاوره ولكن في الاسابيع الماضيه
شاهدنا طبعا بعض التوتر بسبب نشاط
طالبان باكستان
الجماعه
العامه
اسالك كذلك على مساله طالبان الافغانيه
يعني كيف هي همم ما هو دورها وموقفها من
ما يحصل صحيح انه طالب الباكستانيه تقول
انه ليست لها علاقه وانهت هذا الاتفاق
الامني مع اسلام اباد همم كيف هو دور همم
طالبان الافغانيه التي سيطرت على الحكم في
افغانستان حول هذا التوتر الان مع طالبان
الباكستانيه والحكومه في اسلام اباد
حركه
وجود اي عناصر من طالبين باكستان داخل
لافغانستان الحكومه
الافغانيه قالت على الدوام بان
الطالبان
لا تنفذ اي امان طلاقه من افغانستان وان
مات من داخل باكستان لكن الحكومه
الباكستانيه تؤكد بان الهجمات جاءت من
الجانب الافغاني منها
المرجح جدا بانه حكومه باكستان سوف تثير
المساله مع حركه في كابول بجديه اكبر من
اجل وقفي الهجمات التي تبدا
باكستان من قبل حركه الطالبان باكستان من
اسلام اباد رحمه مسعود الصحفيه الباكستاني
شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك الينا الليله
وفي اخبار الساعه بعد قليل الكاميرا
العربيه تلتقي الطفله التي اهداها رونالدو
كره بتوقيعه خلال حفل تقديمه لاعبا للنصر
السعودي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد الاقتصاديه ويعصف
بموظفي الشركات الكبرى في الولايات
المتحده الكبرى الشركات الامريكيه
والتكنولوجيا منها تحديدا اضطرت الى
التخلي عن الاف الموظفين والزيف ولا زال
متوسط عام تقلص حجم الوظائف في الولايات
المتحده بالنسبه 13% في اكتوبر الماضي وهو
الرقم الاعلى منذ فبراير 2011 شركات عملاء
قامت بتصريح موظفين كان اخرها اليوم شركه
امازون التي انهت خدمات ثمانيه عشر الف
موظف استكمالا للسياسه بدات العمل منصرف
نفس الشيء بالنسبه لي تويتر التي قامت
ازيد من 3500 موظف بعد استخدامه ملكيهتها
كما قامت شركه مايكروسوفت لتسريح نحوي في
موظفي اكتوبر بدورها اعلنت شركه المختصه
في التواصل الاجتماعي طبعا في نوفمبر من
العام الماضي انها ستخفض ثلاث 10% من
قوتها العامله
يبدو ان الرئيس تنفيذ شركه امازون يسير
على خطى مالك شركه تويتر الى مصر الموظفين
امازون التي يعمل بها اكثر من مليون و500
الف شخص تستعد لتصريح اكثر من 18 الف موظف
الركود دفع شركات مثل النساء
على خفض الانسان
اركود الاقتصادي يؤثر على سوق العمل في
مختلف بوندان العالم غير ان قطع تكنولوجيا
كان مستهدفا بشكل كبير بحمله الاقالات
الاخيره التي تسببت فيها الازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه العديد من العاملين
في هذا القطاع وجدوا انفسهم امام واقع
مختلف لا تتوفر فيه فرص عمل كافيه فضلا عن
تهديد مستمر بالاقاله سينما وان العديد من
الشركات بدات تجده بدائل الموظفين
المكلفين بالجانب التكنولوجي في ظل التطور
العلمي الحاصل في المجال فحسب استطلاع عن
اجرته مجله تكرانش المختصه في التكنولوجيا
فان حملات الاقالات الاخيره دفعت الكثير
من موظفي القطاع التكنولوجي الى التفكير
في المغادره هذا المجال الكليه
كورونا والحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تتسببان في ركود الاقتصادي
وحمالات الاقاله تتزايد في كل انحاء
العالم من اكثر الفئات المستهدفه موظفو
القطاع التكنولوجي
[موسيقى]
كشف العديد من موظفي القطاع عن غياب
الامان الوظيفي
واعلن اتجاه اكثر نحو المشاريع الخاصه
الموظفين
ومعنا من دبي عبر الزوم دكتور انس
النجداوي اكاديمي والمستشار في اداره
الاعمال الرقميه والتقنيه دكتور انس اهلا
بك معنا هل حقا الركود الاقتصادي هو السبب
الرئيسي في تسريح شركات التكنولوجيا
العملاقه لهذه الاعداد الكبيره من
الموظفين امثله اسباب اخرى
صهيب تحيه لكم المشاهدين
الان حاليا بوجود الاقتصادي وايضا تغيير
بشكل كبير في سلوك المستهلكين واذواقه
طبعا همم تغير كبير هذا اثر بشكل كبير
تحديدا مثلا شركه امازون اثناء الجريح حتى
كل وجبه همم تقريبا على استخدام همم
المنصات او استخدام التجاره الالكترونيه
والشراء كل شيء عن طريق امازون لكن الان
السلوك عاد الى الطبيعه واصبح الاشخاص
يعني يريدون مباشره
وهذا الجانب والجانب اخر ايضا همم يعني
التضخم المالي الذي قلل من قدره
المستهلكين على الشراء وايضا وجود اتطور
التكنولوجيا التي فعليا نعم التقنيه
باتت يعني تحول رقمين كثير من الوظائف
وتستبدل همم بعض من الموظفين باستخدام
يعني التطبيقات الحديثه وهذا فعلا كل هذه
العوامل تلعب دورا مهما في التغيرات على
الباقه دكتور انس يعني هل حقا هذه الشركات
العملاقه يعني كانت هي مجبره فعلا على هذه
الخيارات يعني تسريح الموظفين بهذه
الاعداد ام ااه كان يمكن ان توازن قليلا
وتحتفظ
يعني معين من الموظفين يعني وتسرح حقيقه
الذين لا تحتاج اليهما
يعني نسبه الخساره يعني معدلات الخساره
التي تكملتها هذه الشركات هذا كان عمل
مقلب وهذا تقى لا ناقص الخطر يعني لتلك
الشركات الضخمه والتي اصبحت تريد ان تخفض
وان تعمل بهيكليه يعني اقل من ناحيه
المصاريف هذا طبعا اجبر هذه الشركات فعلين
ان هذا النوع من
السياسات في التسريح ولكنها بلا شك طبعا
تحتفظ يعني نوعيه الموظفين لديهم طبعا
تاثير رئيسي او كبير في همم الابتكار
والابداع
وتسيير العمليات الاساسيه والحيويه اما في
في بعض الوظائف يمكن حاليا استبدالها
الصناعي والتطبيقات
وهذا طبعا يعني اما المحتل يعني سوف تمضي
عليه ايضا يعني همم
السوق اصلا اصبح يمكن وقدره الشرعيه ضعفت
بشكل كبير جدا اا مثل ما تكلمت سابقا
بالمقارنه مع كرونه وهذا طبعا اكثر بشكل
كبير على اربع هذه الشركات فهي مضطره لهذا
النوع من التخليص شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور انس
النجداوي الاكاديمي والمستشار في اداره
الاعمال الرقميه والتقنيه كنت معنا من دبي
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه واصحه الصينيه انها عقد اجتماعا
مع مسؤولين في منظمه الصحه العالميه حول
الوضع الوبائي في البلاد واضافت هيئه
الصحه الصينيه في بيان انها قدمت تقريرا
حول انتشار كورونا في البلاد وما اذا كانت
قد رفضت متحولات جديده من الفيروس اضافه
لخطه العلاج والتطعيم
ومع زياده اصابات كورونا في الصين تشير
الاحصاءات والرسميه لوزاره الصحه الى
انخفاض عدد العاملين في المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه بسبب الاصابات بكرونا في
ما سجل مستشفى تابع لكليه بجامعه
انخفاضا كبيرا في عدد العاملين بالنسبه
لتزيد عن 50% ما اضطر وزاره الصحه الى
زياده عدد الاطباء والممرضين المصابين
لحين تعافى الكادر الطبي من الفيروس
وعودته للعمل
انه متمسكون بوظائفهم والجميع منهمك في
العمل تحت الضغط كبير يجب ان نتفهمهم
ونتعاطفهم
للعوده الى العمل الثلاثاء العاملين في
الكادر الطبي من الشباب جميعهم اكدوا
استمرارهم في العمل
ساذهب للعمل
الان في عياده الحمه
المسؤول الطبيه بانني جاهز للعمل في كل
وقت
هذا هو حذر خبراء الصحه في الولايات
المتحده من انتشار المتحور الجديد من
اوميكرون المعروف باسم اكس بي بي 1.8 في
البلاد وتحديدا في الشمال الشرقي وامكانيه
انتشاره بسرعه في بقيه الولايات الامريكيه
حيث تمثل السلاله الجديده من المتحول نحو
41% من حاله كورونا المؤكده في امريكا
وفقا لبيانات مراكز السيطره على الامراض
والوقايه بعد ان كانت النسبه نحو 12% عشيه
عيد الميلاد
تحضير خبراء الصحه في امريكا رفقه تحذير
اخر هذه المره من خبراء الصحه في بريطانيا
الذين اكدوا ان المملكه المتحده ليست
مستعده لمواجهه لموجه جديده
وحتى الخبراء والبريطانيين على ضروره
ارتداء الكمامه والبقاء في المنازل عند
الشعور بتوعك بسبب المخاوف من ارتفاع
حالات المرض الذي يعتقد انه يشكل 4% على
الاقل من متغيرات كورونا التي تم تتبعها
اجره العربيه لقاء مع الطفله التي اهداها
النجم همم كريستيانو همم رونالدو الكره
بتوقيعه اثناء حفل تقديمه في ملعب مرسول
البارد
[موسيقى]
وزع كريستيانو رونالدو وعدد من الكور خلال
حفل تقديمي في ملعب مرسول مبارك لكن هذه
الكره كانت لافته الذهب كريستيانو رونالدو
وانتقع طفله صغيره من بين الاف الاشخاص
الذين يتواجدوا في الملعب وعليها هي
الطفله الوحيده التي ااه او الشخص الوحيد
حتى في الملعب الذي ذهب اليه كريستيانو
واعطى الكره اليوم
انت ناديتي كريستيانو ولا كريستيانو هو
الي جاك
لما جاك انت عارفه انه حيعطيك الكوره
الناس اللي وراني ولا جنبي ولا انا كنت في
الجزء
الثاني بعيد مره
وجيت وهي معها الكوره وكل احد
يتجمع عليها
ايه عشان كده بتبيعنها لي صح
حلوه من عبد المحسن اخترت مجله ترافلر
المختصه في مجال السفر والسياحه
اختارت مدينه العلا شمال غرب السعوديه ضمن
عجائب الدنيا السبع لعام23 واشاره المجله
الى ان العلا اصبحت ذات شهره العالميه
نظرا لما تختزله من تاريخ واثار لم يكشف
النقاب اليوم وتضم العلامات تاريخيه
انسانيه يظهر من بينها موقع الحجر الذي
بنته ابداعات الحضاره النبطيه وسجل الموقع
بوصفه اول موقع تراث العالمي ضمن لائحه
منظمه اليونيسكو في السعوديه
اخبار الساعه انتهت هذا تفكيره بابره
العلويه
روسيا توقف قسطندونيتك تنفيذ لهده من طرف
واحد كيف ترفضها وتصفها بالنفاق
الجمهوريون يسعون لتجنب المزيد من الاحراج
وانتخاب رئيس جديد للنواب الديمقراطيون ما
اسعدهم
غارات من اسلام اباد على معاقل طالبان
باكستان داخل اراضي افغانستان تشعل الحدود
مجددا
[موسيقى]
توقعاته 2023 تبدا في الحدود مجزره وقلت
في امازون سيرا على خطى المنافسين عام
جديد بلا جديد شكرا لكم على المشاهده الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]